- In this video, I'd like
to give you a few tips
on how to behave on conference calls,
so that it is both effective
and also respectful to the
other members on the call.
I trust this is going to
be especially relevant
in these times where
we know there are just
so much more conference
calls going on than usually.
Hi guys, my name is Heinrich,
and welcome to another Coffee
Break with Firm Learning.
Today I'm talking about conference calls.
And as probably you know,
in consulting, conference
calls are so common,
you probably on a usual day
have more than five
conference calls going on.
Since about half a year ago,
I make the move from
consulting moving into industry
and now I'm working for
a large German retailer.
So I joined at the end of 2019
and at that time our
company was quite unusual
to conference calls.
It was very much a more
classically consultive culture
of people rather prefering to
either just call somebody up
or just meet in person in
order to discuss things.
Where, for obvious reasons, this changed
due to the global
pandemic that is going on
and also hit Germany in a substantial way.
Since several weeks now a large proportion
of our leadership team is in home office
and I work from home office as well.
You're currently seeing me filming this
sitting in my home office in Munich.
And this brought quite a
significant change in culture
in our organization, as now we
have daily conference calls.
Every morning for instance,
there's a conference call check in
with the senior leadership
team of our company.
And both in this retail company
I'm currently working with,
but also in consulting, I've been working
with several clients, I've
observed a whole number of habits
that people have on conference calls
which are just either disturbing
for the majority of the people,
or just plain ineffective
for the objective of the conference call.
Namely having a good and
to the point discussion
of the topics at hand that
just need to be solved
by the team that is now
just talking together.
So in this video I like
to give you five tips
on what you can do
in order to make your
conference calls more effective
and less of an annoyance
to all the people on there.
And if you find this useful
feel free to forward this video
to some of your co-workers as well
so that your conference call experience
hopefully improves for
your whole organization.
So first thing,
and this might seem to be one
of the more obvious things.
Go on mute.
It is incredible to me that most people
who are dialed in on a
conference call are not on mute
and just have the microphone
on the whole time,
even though they are not talking.
And this is irritating and disturbing
for some obvious reasons.
Even though it might
be quiet where you sit
at the moment right now,
it can always happen
that an ambulance passes by your street
or there's some other sudden noises
that suddenly come up that
then disturb the whole call.
And even if there not some
hidden sudden loud noises,
just you sitting in
front of your computer,
pressing buttons on your
keyboard, maybe eating something,
maybe your neighbor's saying
something in a loud way,
all of these are things
which are disturbing,
which create a constant
level of background noise,
which is just not helpful
when you want to have a good discussion
in your conference call.
So my first advice is whenever
you do not talk, go on mute.
This is the absolute
minimum that you need to do
in order to be respectful
to your other co-workers.
Go on mute and unmute yourself
just whenever you really
need to say something.
And if you don't need to
say something, go on mute
to not let other people be disturbed
by the background noises
that you will have
while being on the microphone.
Now the second tip.
And this is something that
I think we all know as well.
And to what extent this issue exists
also depends on the conference call system
that you are using.
But very frequently you
hear in the background
these automated voices of
the conference call system
saying something like,
"Peter joined the call."
"Peter dropped the call."
So whenever somebody
joins or drops the call,
in many conference call systems,
there's an automated voice saying that
to all the people in the call.
And of course if you've been there,
if you've seen these kind of things,
this is extremely disturbing
because if somebody
joins or drops the call,
basically the conversation
is interrupted by that voice.
So how can you diminish this disturbance
as much as possible?
Well, and again, this
very much also depends
on the conference call
system that you're using,
how exactly that works.
But frequently whenever you
dial into a conference call,
the system often asks you for your name.
So let's say something like,
"Please tell us your
name after the beep sound
and then press the hash button."
Right, so it asks you to say your name
and then press the button,
usually the hash key
so that the system knows
that now the recording
can stop of your name.
So what you need to do,
with a little trick here
is that when you're being
asked to tell your name,
just don't tell your name.
Just don't say anything and
directly press the hash key.
So it asks you, then you directly press it
without any second left
so that it cannot really record anything
and then when you join or
when you drop the call,
there will just be no sound of the system
saying your name to everybody
because this recording of
your name just doesn't exist.
So whenever the system
asks you for your name,
press the hash key, don't say your name,
and you will be fine.
Of course if there's a
strict rule in your company
that you need to say your
name, well then do that,
don't get in trouble for that.
But most companies, there
isn't anything like that,
and I can tell you if you do this
and if you tell your
co-workers to do this,
your conference calls
will go much more smoothly
because this kind of disturbance
just isn't there anymore.
So guys my third tip is about what to do
when you actually join
the conference call late.
And of course this can happen
for all kinds of reasons,
but what many people do,
which I find quite
disrespectful and disturbing,
is the person's late, the
discussion is already ongoing,
and then the person joins the call
and then just says something like,
"Hi guys, Heinrich here,
I'm late, sorry for that.
"I was just stuck in
traffic, but now I'm here.
"Sorry for that. "
Right, and by doing that he disrupts,
he interrupts the whole conversation
and just stops the person
who was currently doing.
And especially in large conference calls,
where there are many
people online in the call
and many people coming late,
if all these people then
apologized for being late
and then in the worst case
even also give a reason
why they were late, this
is just such a disturbance.
So from my experience, the
best practice really is,
if you are joining the conference call
and you are late, just say nothing.
Don't introduce yourself
that you are there now.
Don't apologize why you
are late, just say nothing.
And this is especially
true if you can hear
that the call already started
and there's already a
conversation going on.
And of course, that might be
different if you are the CEO
of the company or if you are the person
who is actually supposed to
lead the whole conference call.
You're just the most
important person in the call,
then maybe it's okay and
then maybe makes sense
that you let all the others
know that you are there.
But if you are just one
of many participants,
most likely be others will not really care
if you're there or not.
Or at least they won't
care as much for you
to interrupt the whole discussion
just for letting them know.
So just be quiet and just
use the next opportunity
where you see a moment
when you can just add something meaningful
to the discussion, where you can say that
and then also by doing that
letting the others know
that now you joined the call as well.
The fourth tip on conference
calls is to be concise.
So for all these reasons and many others,
conference calls can be
quite tiresome and annoying.
Everybody should contribute
for making these calls
as short and as efficient as possible.
And we all know these
people who just in meetings
and conversations need
to have their stage time.
These people that feel
like that they always need
to say something that even though
that has been already said many times,
they need to repeat it again.
People that state the obvious
just to say something.
This is annoying and
this is not only annoying
in conference calls, but of course also
in regular meetings as well.
But this is especially
annoying in conference calls
because conference calls
in itself often are a bit
of an annoying situation and
this only makes it worse.
So make sure that when you say something
it really adds value to the conversation,
you're not just repeating things
that others have already said.
You're not stating the obvious.
So things that are completely obvious
but you just say them just
because you feel like you
need to say something.
Do not do these things.
Be concise for the sake
of everybody involved.
And now my fifth tip
is, if any how possible,
only join the call if you have a more
or less stable connection.
I mean also we've all
been in these situations
where people join from an airport,
maybe already sitting in an airplane,
or they join from the car,
or they join from the train,
and then they constantly
lose the connection,
drop off the call, then drop in again.
And this is just a disturbance
because even if you do not say
your name at the beginning,
so it does not always say
"Peter joined or left the call."
Often there's at least the beeping sound
which is a disturbance.
So if you already know
that you will not have a stable connection
for your telephone conference
and if there's any way for you
that may be your attendance
isn't absolutely crucial,
or maybe there's a way to
postpone it to a moment
where you actually have
a more stable connection.
Do not join if your connection is unstable
because again, it is a big disturbance
to all the other people on the call.
It is annoying and it's a waste of time,
so be respectful to the
time of your co-workers.
So, these were my five tips.
And of course I'm interested now to hear
how has your work environment
changing in these dire times,
in this global pandemic?
Is it true for you as well
that you are now having
many more conference calls?
Let me know what your experience
is below in the comments.
I'd love to hear from you and
if you have any other tips
that you'd like to
share with our community
here on Firm Learning, let us know.
I'm sure that others
would appreciate as well
what are your do's and
don'ts for having good
and effective telephone conferences.
And of course, if you took
any value out of this video
at all, if always, please
press the like button
to help the YouTube algorithm
let other people find this video as well.
And if you'd like to see more videos
on how you can be successful
in the first years of your
career, videos similar like this,
please press the subscribe button.
Of course I'd also love
to hear your feedback,
topics you'd like to see
covered in this channel.
Just let me know and I
can put this on my list
of ideas for the future videos.
I will release at least
one video every week,
so thank you for hanging in here with me.
Thank you for joining.
Thank you for watching.
My name is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Stay safe everybody and have a good day.